[Music]
you know what time it is
it's our favorite reddit section I [ __ ]
the dog no I I have been there actually
wolf for that particular line all right
so am I the [ __ ] for telling my
family to stay out stay out of me and my
fight my fiance's financial agreement
fiance and financially [ __ ] mean that
if they keep bothering me they can't
come to the wedding anymore
let me guess is she like giving all her
money to him no oh babies mamas are
coming and nope
it's a financial thing it's a financial
thing that their parents aren't cool
with all right all right so here we go
all the way off so my fiance and I have
a large wealth discrepancy my
grandparents gave me and my sister a
large amount of money when they died and
I have a much higher paying job than him
he works just as hard as me he just gets
paid less the way our finances work
right now is I pay most of our
day-to-day expenses but he gets me nice
birthday and Christmas presents last
Christmas he got me a really beautiful
necklace that he wouldn't have been able
to afford if I made him pay rent on the
apartment so he contributes just as much
as he normally would if he paid rent but
this makes me feel better
the read doesn't suddenly cost more
because he lives there I was paying it
by myself anyway my parents pestered me
and pestered me to explain to them how
he was paying half the rent
on our apartment with his job because he
shouldn't get paid enough to afford it
while also buying everything else he
does I finally told them a few months
ago that he doesn't pay the rent they
basically had a meltdown over and told
me to break up with him don't go through
the wedding etc so I called him over
Mother's Day and they spent the whole
time asking if I had started making my
fiance pay rent
I finally got sick of sick of it and
told them no
two blood out and if they keep pestering
me about our personal finances that they
couldn't come to the wedding
they had another meltdown and I was
horrible for even bringing up the
possibility that I wouldn't invite them
to the wedding was that threat too far I
mean my mom called me crying today
apologizing and basically groveling to
come and I feel like [ __ ] am I the
[ __ ] kind of an [ __ ] well for me
it's like that it's like it's like - did
I see a lot of different layers to this
right so the first one obviously it
sounds like her parents are pretty
traditional and they they they see it as
the man should be taking care of the
woman obviously the daughter doesn't see
it that way she seems to be happy she
seems to have like like that dynamic
that's cool but she also failed to see
that like her parents care about her and
it's coming from a good place
she doesn't have to be so extreme and be
like you can't come to my wedding it's
like she could just be like hey like I'm
happy this is what I want to do like
over parents are so annoying though they
are annoying but what's really gonna
happen what are they gonna do literally
like hey you cannot marry this guy but
if you do we better get an invite yeah
that's basically what they're saying
they're like you got to call off the
wedding cuz he's not paying the rent but
it's yeah but I feel like I mean it's
coming from a place of like they're they
just want to take care so do you think
we're taking care taking taking
advantage of him they don't want that's
not what they said they do but they if
he had a higher paying job you wouldn't
have said anything
well I think oh oh you're right I think
they're probably seeing it as like this
is our daughter because they're sound
very traditional they're like we want to
make sure baby's taken care of and we
don't have to worry about her well-being
oh she's got money she's got a high
paying job can't afford to pay for the
whole thing up in it
doesn't seem like it hurts at all it
doesn't seem like she's paying for all
this [ __ ] except like the rent and stuff
but he's happily with the mountain money
he's making he's trying out he's trying
to buy her gifts and like show
appreciation to her and she seems to
like those types of guess I think she
sucks at answering to her parents but
she also said
so said the part that likes that got to
me too they were like wait how can you
afford to buy everything that he buys
and then still pay rent so like they
might be seeing as he's recklessly
spending but beneath avoiding the red
[ __ ] she's just like oh yeah I just
never asked don't worry about it no so
in here it says that the money that he
would have spent on rent yeah it goes to
her Christmas gift and it goes to her
birthday so it literally goes to her but
I'm thinking should those things be
independent from each other well there's
the thing right now if she's like oh
don't pay rent at all and he's like oh I
want to but he doesn't let me sure you
know I'll just buy her things don't pay
rent buy me a bunch of oh I've been
living independently for so long yeah
she's probably like I don't need it cuz
her cuz it was the waste that she's
paying right you know here or not it's
not changing how much I would be paying
so she's like I don't really care it's
like why split the bill yeah if I had a
girlfriend I want her to move in and
like say I already lived on the spot and
I wanted her to come so you have a
girlfriend go ahead nothing to do with
[Music]
and I wanted her to move in you guys
mania you can't stop him cool laughing
to your state what would you like that
that he had his own thought in his own
head he wasn't even listening to you
that's the point the very sorry you're
not even in the room right now okay so -
laughs what about say we're a [ __ ]
wasting film try not to laugh here we go
and then I heard of
that's let's say there was a girl that
won and I wanted to move in and she was
like it's [ __ ] up I can't afford it
but I'm like no I'm already here like I
don't want you wouldn't have pay as much
that it's very feasible that's fine yeah
I would do the same thing as sewers do
it then I think the parents are like
kind of having like a power like dynamic
thing like they want they want the
daughter to be with someone all the
status or more right and then this guy
is well below what they thought after
all these traditional families like
every generation looked at their kids
like the same way that the her parents
looking at her so how is she gonna look
at her kids and what are they gonna be
doing she met someone got a break this
is she might be the change I feel like
maybe they're worried that he's conning
her maybe
he's freeloading off of her yeah cuz
they don't even ask like you know like
like anything else but everything yeah
they're just like is he paying half the
rent here you pay half the rent
and she also sucks at explaining saying
like well we have an agreement where
half of that money that he'd that's
supposed to go to rad just goes to my
necklace and cuz I want these nice
things and [ __ ] maybe she doesn't say it
like that so that would make it worse
for them really yeah still doesn't make
sense economically right what kinda job
does he have so now saying okay so you
could have paid you but you'd rather
have necklaces yeah then it makes it
kind of materialistic out of it and it's
kind of like weird I would personally be
pissed off if okay let's say that I
don't get fair equal value and they're
out there buying a lot of [ __ ] for
themselves also she didn't say that in
there that's I was like yeah I should
kind of sound like an ass a little bit
she's but who's buying it for themselves
uh in there she says that her parents
questioned her and her dude because they
were like wait how does he get to buy
all this [ __ ] for himself yeah but he
doesn't like afford rent with what he oh
no he doesn't straight-up fuse he
doesn't pay rent we was [ __ ] part
that you're saying that makes her
[ __ ] with that no no I think we move
past them you know so it sounds like
this dude is kind of selfish because not
only does he not pay rent he's out
you're buying all these fun things for
themselves so that part stood out to me
they didn't specify what he's buying but
the parents are like there's they're
like pestering to explain to them how
you pay how he's paying half of their
stuff on the rent because how is he
affording this while also buying
everything else he does so what
everything else
maybe he posted on insta but it also
about like what he does from working how
much he makes there I mean it could it
could come up in casual conversation
like if he's buying a [ __ ] Rolex
every week right cuz obviously it sounds
like she has a very large wealth
discrepancy she has a huge [ __ ]
amount of money when their parents
grandparents died right so what if the
inheritance is like massive and he's out
here trying to live it up to that luxury
world that makes sense oh yeah he's
trying to catch up with her yeah that
makes so awesome she might be buying a
Rolex every month and her parents are
like how does he do this as a [ __ ]
moccasin so solar or something dude can
you imagine if you're you you're like
your girlfriend is like some daughter of
a billionaire some [ __ ] do you imagine
the [ __ ] that you would have to try to
do to press her ass are one of our
friends uh uh oh it had a really rich
girlfriend and it didn't work out
because they were just so massively rich
and he couldn't just keep up yeah what
did he do well he was a good little
prince that was taken care of like
first-class tickets to Asia all this
stuff and he started to feel like
inadequate yeah I say [ __ ] sure because
to me it's like I wouldn't feel that way
I feel like I won the lotto why do you
think but do people win the lotto blow
it this is like crazy rich Asians no no
crazy train it's like the one with Ali
Wong crazy rich Asians
no no Ali Wong is another the romantic
comedy on Netflix
my one that's rich always be my babies
yeah baby yeah so then she's the one
that's always rich and he feels
inadequate because he doesn't have
enough money okay and it's even worse
for a dude because of how we were raised
masculinity that [ __ ] with people
didn't seem to have a problem with it it
seems like two consenting adults doing
their contracting lives that's what for
me I was feeling a little bit like she's
not understanding where her parents are
coming from in the era that they come
from so for her to snap back as hard as
she did without really seeing what their
intent is what do you feel like how
would you bridge that gap for your
parents uh I would see I would I would
really try to look at how they were
raised
right so that I can understand their
mindset and then I can I can see what
they're really trying to tell me opposed
to just listening to their war then how
would you try to make your parents okay
with it because they don't want you to
get married and you're about to be
married yeah I mean I would just tell
them like hey like it's still ultimately
my life and you raised a good daughter
and you have to trust that what you
instilled in me I have it she sucks that
explain like it's ultimately what I have
to do it's like you have to be like an
adult you know sometimes like if you're
like say tyka start dating this girl I
was just using him for his money I'm
[ __ ] her ass up right but then you
know you can see it but attack is like
no I'm in love he has to fall on his
face you know what I mean like oh you
have to how you would tell them I have
to because I know that's the only way I
learn so for me to like hold someone's
hand and like try to shelter them from
[ __ ]
that's how my parents what are you doing
that job of explaining maybe her parents
she's not learned like that you know
what I mean
I'm saying like maybe her parents could
do a better job and she could do a
better job too of explaining everyone
could do try to change people but how
often does that work it's better than
just being like this and making you
resign your parents I rather be like
[ __ ] you mom and walk out the door
that'll show her I think that's what
she's yeah that's doing
[Music]
[Music]